hello readers i want to talk to you
today about point of view in literature
and how it can shape what we as readers
take away from a story
now we've talked about this in more
basic terms before is a story in first
second or third person but i would like
to go deeper
once we've sussed out whose perspective
a story or a poem is being told from
what's next what else is there to talk
about
well i think it's useful to remember
that stories and poems don't just happen
they don't just suddenly spontaneously
exist creating them is work and it's the
result of a whole bunch of decisions
made by a writer so who is the point of
view character or characters what does
that mean for the story ultimately a
point of view is an author's decision so
when an author chooses to center a story
on one character how does that change
the story they tell
would the story be different if it were
centered on a different character how
does that point of view impact the way
the story gets told
imagine a rocket scientist with a mouse
in her pocket and they're going to
inspect a spaceship under construction
i'm going to give you two little
snippets in what's called close third
person perspective where there's a
narrator but their point of view is
attached to a character we get to see
through their eyes experience their
thoughts
so first we're going to hear from the
rocket scientist
leaving the lab dr harper strode
confidently into the spaceship hanger
clipboard in hand pet mouse in pocket
launch day was only eight months away
and project juno still had so many bugs
to work out but she was certain that the
tests she'd conduct today would help her
solve the air filter problem
the starship sat before her in a pool of
light a deep bluish black craft
once an idea that had lived only in her
mind but now it was a real physical
object
she dug around in her pocket and fed
persephone a sunflower seed
now let's take that again from the
mouse's perspective
persephone t mouse clung to the lip of
tatiana's jacket pocket as they passed
from a small cold room into a much
larger warmer and brighter room
it had been four hours since she'd had
anything to eat and she was cranky
in the middle of the big bright room was
a big bluish black shape
persephone didn't know what it was and
frankly it looked kind of like a bird
which was weird and a little frightening
but it hadn't moved the last time
persephone and tatiana were in there and
it wasn't moving now so persephone
guessed it was asleep
she chirped impatiently and tatiana gave
her a sunflower seed
you see the same things happen in each
story dr harper goes from her lab to the
spaceship hanger and then she feeds her
pet mouse a sunflower seed
but when we hang out with harper's
perspective we get her thoughts and we
see what she thinks is important but
when we read from persephone the mouse's
perspective like she doesn't care about
the spaceship she doesn't know what it
is
as readers it's useful to ask how a
writer is developing a character's point
of view through a story
what are the abilities and limitations
of a point of view character persephone
the mouse is small she can sneak through
little holes in the wall or hide in the
jacket pocket of a consenting human
being but dr harper has you know an
astrophysics doctorate and opposable
thumbs she can open doors design a
spaceship plan its flight trajectory
this is kind of an extreme example
because one of these characters is a
human being and the other one is a mouse
but even among different people we can
imagine very different stories
characters and stories are just like
real people they have strengths and
weaknesses knowledge about some things
and ignorance about others
sometimes they tell the truth and
sometimes they lie
this is especially important in first
person books where everything we read
comes to us directly from the point of
view character
you have to open yourself up to the
possibility that the narrator can be
wrong about stuff
they can perceive things incorrectly or
be blinded by their own assumptions or
just be confused
they could also just be lying
but they could also just be innocently
wrong and confused they could look at a
spaceship and think it's a bird
narrators that are wrong or misinformed
or are actively trying to trick you are
called unreliable narrators
reading a book narrated by an unreliable
narrator turns the relatively
straightforward process of reading into
a tug-of-war
how do i know i can trust what the
narrator is telling me
ask yourself what does a narrator think
what do they feel and what do they do
when you can answer all of those
questions you can begin to put their
perspective into words if you can
identify the biases or the perspective
or the ignorance of a point of view
character you can start to correct for
it as you read and use that
understanding of the point of view to
better understand the story as a whole
something important to remember is that
the storytelling character is not the
same thing as the author the author
creates those characters and is
literally the person who writes the
words but if i wrote a story about an
ogre who eats children that does not
make me an ogre who eats children i
would never eat children
they taste horrible
you can learn anything
dave it out